as a kid when um
when I you know was even going to school
and stuff I didn't think that there
would be a place for me in in society
you know in just uh you know even
fitting in within teenagers and you know
all those labels matter so much so for
the recording Academy to to on honor me
for the work that I put in and um to to
you know I was a singer who had
transgender in front of their name for
years you know as the first thing people
know about me and it just feels as a
musician and someone who's put in uh
years and years or over 10 years of
writing songs and being in the industry
it feels uh incredible I'm so grateful
to Sam for
um putting me on that beautiful song and
I love that song and uh yeah you know I
was happy dancing on tables and gay
clubs and people were like yeah she
makes gay club music and now I make gay
club music they got a Grammy Kim Petras
reacts to making history as the first
transgender woman to win a Grammy the 30
year old took home the award for best
pop or group performance alongside Sam
Smith for their hit song Unholy so how
does Kim plan to celebrate her big win
definitely gotta get a drink because I
was performing I was always I never
drink before so it's time for a drink uh
I hope I see some cool people
um I mean uh yeah I just I'm definitely
going to some parties that I've been
invited to I'm here at the universal
Grammy's party and my I love my label
and my family there so I'm excited to
see them and to celebrate with them
right now and then let's see where the
night takes us but definitely reuniting
with Sam as well the pop star also
weighs in on another history maker from
music's biggest night Beyonce who is now
officially the most awarded Grammy
artist of all time with 32 wins holy I
mean Beyonce has been such a incredible
performer for it so long uh this album
changed so many lives and really honored
uh ballroom and uh kind of you know the
the New York party live that that I uh
you know I was a party kid for a long
time I've experienced that stuff and
it's so cool that she
um you know was inspired by that and I
love that album I think it's incredible
and I think Beyonce is probably the
hardest working person on the planet and
deserves everything on in the world you
know so yeah Beyonce's Crazy talented
and insanely the best performer ever so
I think everyone just looks up to
Beyonce and well deserved so deserved
Queen
[Music]
foreign